[Applause]
I grew up on a beef farm in Missouri and
like everybody else that raises
livestock, we raise a lot of our own
feed to stay in business and we raise
corn and soybeans and hay and we grind
this stuff up into a flour and we'd add
vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals, make pellets. You feed those
calves for about 6,9 months and then you
ship them off to be butchered or maybe
to other feeders and you always save
back the very best ones for yourself and
you knock them in the head and eat them.
It's a real simple cycle on the farm.
And the thing that fascinated me as a
teenager was that we went to a great
deal of trouble for those calves and yet
as a family we ate out of the very same
fields. We'd keep back five rows of corn
for oursel. We had a garden at the end
of the field where we grew our peas and
beans and squash and tomatoes. And we
wanted to live to be a hundred with no
aches and pains. and we didn't give
ourselves the very same vitamins and
minerals and trace minerals that we gave
the calves. And I always used to ask my
dad, I say, "Hey pops, how come we go to
all that trouble for those calves and
not for oursel?" And he'd say, "Shut up,
boy. Getting farm fresh food, fresh air,
lots of free exercise. Don't ask
complicated questions." And I was glad
to get rid of the farm exercise and go
to a school at the University of
Missouri. And there my major was in
animal husbandry and nutrition. My minor
was in field crops and soils. And I
began to learn technical things about
soil chemistry and how it related to
tons and bushels per acre and a
economics. But I didn't get an answer to
my basic question until I became a
freshman veterinary student at the
University of Missouri. And there I
learned that the reason why we put all
these vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals into animal feeds, bottom line,
is because we don't have insurance for
them. We don't have Blue Cross, Blue
Shield, major medical hospitalization,
Medicare, Medicaid. And if we were to
use a human health care type of system
for animals, it'd be sticker shock for
you. and your hamburger would cost you
$275 a pound. Boneless, skinless chicken
breast would be $450 bucks a pound.
Dozen eggs would be $50 just to pay for
the health care. So, we learned that we
could keep the price of animal products
such as meat and dairy and poultry and
eggs down to where the average American
could afford them simply by
significantly reducing or totally
eliminating health care costs. And we do
that in animals by preventing and curing
diseases with nutrition. Well, after
graduating vet school, I went to Africa
for a couple of years and got to work
with Marlon Perkins from the old Mutual
of Omaha Wow Kingdom days. That was kind
of a kick. Got to play Frank Buck, use a
tranquilizer gun Trump all over Central
and South Africa for a couple of years.
And then Marlon sent me a telegram and
invited me back to the States. Uh he'd
gotten a $7.5 million grant from the
National Institutes of Health and this
was more than 30 years ago. And this was
to study pollution and ecology and the
environment. And my job as the wildlife
veterinarian on the project was to do
autopsies of animals that died of
natural causes in the big zoos around
the United States. And I was supposed to
identify or find a species of animals
that was ultra sensitive to pollution.
And we're going to use that animal much
like the old coal miners used to use
canaries. You know how that goes. They
take the canary down in the mine and if
methane gas or carbon monoxide were to
leak in the mine, the canaries were more
sensitive than the men and uh would drop
off the Persian die and long before the
men were in danger of suffocating or
blowing up. Well, to make a long story
short, after some 12 plus years of
working on this project, I had done some
17,500 autopsies and over 454 species of
animals plus 3,000 human beings for a
comparison. And what I learned was that
every animal and human being who dies of
natural causes dies of a nutritional
deficiency disease. And I got kind of
excited about nutrition again. And I
wrote 75 scientific papers on the
subject. Uh wrote chapters for eight
multi-author textbooks. Actually
contributed a textbook myself, a
thousand pages, 2,000 illustrations. and
uh through the news releases that were
in the big universities I worked with. I
was on 2020 was in 1,700 newspapers
around the world through the UPI and AP
newswire services and with all this
public exposure and with all this
scientific exposure I couldn't get
people who are in a position of
authority either in medical research or
in politics to get too concerned or
interested in preventing and curing
diseases in human beings with nutrition
just like we did in animals. Well, I got
frustrated enough. I went back to school
in Portland, Oregon, became a physician,
and I practiced there for 12 years as a
general family practitioner, and uh I
sewed up chainsaw wounds, delivered
babies, um used everything that I
learned in veterary nutrition on my
human patients. And it was no surprise
to me that it worked just as well in
people as it did in
animals. Well, to get started, I always
like to talk about longevity. And the
human being has the genetic potential to
live healthy, to be 120. I'm going to
prove that to you in just a minute.
Unfortunately, Americans do a lousy job
when it comes to longevity. Our average
lifespan in the United States is 75.5,
about half what we're genetically
capable of. In 1990, when the World
Health Organization examined the top 32
industrialized nations on Earth, the
United States came out 17th. There was
actually 16 other countries whose
peoples live longer than we do. We
ranked 19th in healthfulness. That meant
that there were 18 other countries whose
peoples live longer than we do before
they develop heart disease and cancer
and diabetes and arthritis and
osteoporosis. We ranked 23rd when it
came to live birth and first year
survivability as a babies. And we ranked
dead last 32 out of 32 when it came to
preventing birth defects. Now what all
this means is we have the highest price
health care system in the world but not
the best. It also means that we have the
most envied health care system in the
world but not the best. We have the most
technologically advanced health care
system in the world but not the best. I
had a good friend by the name of
Christopher Bird for many many years
over 20 years and Chris was a
best-selling author on books on our
gangler grown food. He was an expert in
this subject and I was always trying to
give him vitamins and minerals and he
refused to take them and he tell me doc
I bring my own cooler. I don't eat any
uh hotel food. I bring my own
organically grown food and so I don't
need to take vitamins and minerals.
While I was changing planes uh again in
Atlanta, had an hour to kill. picked up
the local newspaper and guess whose
obituary I found in the newspaper? Chris
Bird. Of course, again, he was a
best-selling author of books, The Secret
Life of Plants, The Secrets of the Soil.
And he died at age 68 from a ruptured
aneurysm, a type of stroke, 7 and a half
years before the average American dies.
And he led a pristine life, lived up in
the mountains, had an organically grown
garden, collected herbs, you know, like
Ule Gibbons and ate wild hickory nuts
and all those kind of things. And
because of his belief, he died of a
copper deficiency. And I'll show you in
a minute that copper deficiency causes
ruptured aneurysms. And it's just a
tragic thing that the people have so
much to give and die at less than half
their genetic potential for longevity. A
lot of people say to me, "Doc, I don't
need to take vitamins and minerals and
trace minerals because I use herbs."
Now, herbs are not nutrition. You have
to understand that herbs are not
nutrition. They are great plant
medicines. Uh they're safer. They're
more economical. In most cases, are more
effective than prescription medications
that doctors will give you. But they're
plant medicines. If you have diarrhea,
they can tighten you up. If you have
constipation, they can loosen you up. If
you have hypertension or high blood
pressure, then bring it down. If you
have a fever, then bring it down. But
don't expect to get enough calcium or
selenium or boron or copper or vitamin A
from herbs. Well, I've been doing
biomedical research and clinical
research in animals and human beings.
And I can tell you no matter how you
look at health and longevity, whether it
be in animals or human beings, there's
only really two concepts you have to
deal with. Concept number one I refer to
as avoid stepping on the landmines. This
is where you don't want to throw away
your healthy physical body wastefully.
You don't want to smoke. Don't abuse
alcohol. Don't do drugs. Don't jog down
the highway at two o'clock in the
morning wearing an all black ninja suit.
You're going to get hit by a truck
mirror. Right? Whenever a doctor says,
"Here's our options." Never say, "Doc,
whatever you say, you're the you're the
doctor." When a doctor says, "Here's our
options." What you want to do is say,
"Look, I want copies of all these
records and tests. I want copies of the
X-rays." And go visit three other
doctors and three other hospitals. You
want to talk to 12 of their living
patients that had gone through this
procedure. Talk to them. See, if you
really want to do this, I mean, you do
this for your driveway and your roof and
your fence and your yard and all that
kind of stuff. Why not for your own
physical body? That's concept number
one. Now that you've avoided the
landmines, you're in a good position to
do all the positive things that you need
to do to go on to live to be over 100.
Basically, what you want to do is take
all the essential nutrients. 60, that's
6 O minerals, 16 vitamins, 12 essential
amino acids, and three essential fatty
acids. And they're called essential
nutrients for two reasons. Number one,
your body cannot manufacture them. You
must consume these every day, either as
food or supplements. Number two, if any
one of these essential nutrients is
missing for a couple of months, couple
of years, you get on the average 10
deficiency diseases. You have everything
to gain, nothing to lose by
supplementing properly. Well, the
medical profession of course has this
malignant dumb belief that you can get
everything you need from your four food
groups. My favorite article of all time
in the press was April 6th, 1992. Time
magazine cover article, the real power
of vitamins, new research shows it may
help fight cancer, heart disease, and
the ravages of aging. Six positive
pages. If you haven't read it, I'd urge
you to go to a public library, school
library, dig it out, and read it. There
was only one negative sentence and as
you might guess it was offered by a
medical doctor who was actually uh uh
contacted by the writer of the article
said, "What do you think about vitamins
and minerals and and trace minerals as
supplements for human nutrition?" Here's
what he said. Quote, "Popping vitamins
doesn't do you any good?" sniffs Dr.
Victor Herbert, a professor of medicine
at New York City's Mount Sinai Medical
School. We get all the vitamins we need
in our diets, and taking supplements
just gives you expensive urine." Now,
Missouri translation of that is, "You're
just peeing away your money. You might
as well wad up your dollars, throw them
in a toilet, and flush them away. You
can get everything you need from your
four food groups is what he's trying to
say. Well, I'd rather pee out 50 cents
or a dollar a day worth of excess
vitamins and minerals. That's cheap
insurance. Think about it. How much
money you spend for coffee or soft
drinks or newspapers and that kind of
stuff every day. 50 cents to a dollar a
day to maintain and repair your body.
And it's kind of fascinating that most
people don't do it. Just remember when
you pay that doctor out of your own
pocket or indirectly through insurance
or indirectly through taxes and
Medicare, Medicaid, not a single penny
of that goes to better understand,
manage, treat, prevent or cure
catastrophic diseases in kids, breast
cancer and women, prostate cancer and
men. And a lot of people asked me, why
did you call your original tape deads
don't lie? Well, that's because I I
believed for a long time because I'd
done medical research for over 20 years
in large medical research institutes,
medical schools, the various
laboratories. And I always had a belief
in the medical system. But I I was very
disappointed when I learned that doctors
don't know the most about health and
longevity. Doctors don't know the most
about disease. They do know about
procedures. You know, how to fix your
bones when you break them and that sort
of thing, how to do a CAT scan. And so I
began to look in the medical journals
and sure enough the first article ever
published on health and longevity of
American doctors was published in JAMAMA
in June 15, 1895, a little over 100
years ago. They said at that time
doctors lived to be
54.6. I redid the study 97 years later
using the same obituary techniques that
they did in JAMAMA. This was um January
20th, 1993, that particular issue of
JAMAMA. And it turned out the doctors
lived to be 57.6. I round it up to 58 to
give them the benefit of the doubt. And
doctors just went berserk when I said
that. I mean, this was the most
outrageous thing that they ever heard.
My principle is my my premise is that
doctors don't live as long as the
average couch potato in America. And I
purposely put that figure out there at
58 to try and challenge people. Well,
doctors immediately looked at all the
insurance actuarial charts. They got
250,000 dead doctors. They said, "Your
group's too small." So, they looked at
250,000 dead doctors. They say, "Doctors
don't live to be 58. They died 62. They
still don't live to be 75.5 like the
average couch potato. We actually reran
this again using the entire obituary
history for 1996. And for the entire
1996 of all the doctors dying in 1996
with all the medical treatments and
drugs and and procedures and everything
and transplants, doctors in that study
lived to be 70. Still five and a half
years short of the average couch potato
in America. So they still have never
proven that doctors live as long as
everybody else. And that's why dead
doctors don't lie.
Now, if you do everything right, how old
can you live to be? Is it worth all the
effort? I believe it is. Here's one.
Christian Mortonson from San Rafale,
California, in August of 1995, turned
113. August of 1996, he turned 114. He's
still going strong. Certainly can live
to be 115. Smokes a couple of cigars a
day like George Burns, who also lived to
be over 100. Certainly was. I guess the
only exercise George Burns ever did was
put the cigars in his mouth. This gal
here, Dora Ramothi from South Africa in
July of 1995 turned 114. And when she
was asked by the media, Dora, what do
you attribute your health and longevity
to? She did not say that we owe it all
to our annual physical or our HMO. She
said, I ate locust every day. You know,
a little grasshopper. She's not a
vegetarian. She eats little animals.
Pumpkin seeds, tortoise meat, wild
herbs, dried fruit, and starts each day
with a cup of coffee. This gal here,
Margaret Skez from Radford, Virginia, in
1994 was the oldest documented living
American when she died at age 115, fell
over and fractured her hip. Three weeks
later, she was dead from complications
of osteoporosis, a simple calcium
deficiency. And we'll talk more about
this in a minute. Unfortunately, this is
not unusual. 75% of all Americans over
the age of 65 who fracture a hip or
major leg bone don't live 90 days. They
die of pneumonia, pulmonary embolism,
stroke, and other complications of that
fracture. Susie Brunson according to her
family in December of 1994 was the
oldest American when she died at age 123
and they base her claim on her birth
date December 25th 1870 which is
recorded in the family bible. Then this
fellow here, Francisco Barrison Wave at
Choparina October 1995. He was from a
little town outside of Bogota, Columbia,
turned 125. When he was asked by the
media, Francisco, what do you attribute
your health and longevity to, he said,
well, I drink a gallon of goat milk
every day. Also, it's kind of
fascinating in his birthday
announcement, this is not obituary, this
is a birthday announcement, said that
over 40 years ago, his physicians told
him he only had a couple of months to
live. So, he had his sons build him a
coffin. And uh he's been waking up every
morning for more than 40 years sitting
by that coffin waiting to die.
good night time comes, he goes to bed,
wakes up the next morning, sits by the
coffin, waits to die. Now, he's still
going strong, and all the doctors who
told him that more than 40 years ago are
long since dead. Now, this fellow here,
Hammoodi El Abdullah from Syria, died
age 133, and he was still fathering
children after the age of 100. He um
remarried for the fourth time when he
was age 80, fathered four boys, five
girls, nine children after the age of 80
with the same wife. And you add up the
pregnancies and the breastfeeding, the
time in between pregnancies, he was
still fathering children after the age
of 100. Now, this very next one is my
very, very favorite. This gal, Mazumi
Dusty from Iran, according to the Rocky
Mountain News Wire Services out of
Denver and the Iranian news agency, this
was January of 1995. She died at age
161. Now, you have to give a certain
amount of credibility to this obituary
report that she died at age 161 because
she was survived by six living children
ranging in age from 120 to 128. They
hadn't even left home to go to college
yet. Now, her oldest son, Golam, said
his mother had never visited a doctor or
taken any chemical medications during
her life did take a few herbs. So, if
you kind of think about it, every one of
these people who live to be over 100,
120, 130, 160. These people are not from
United States or Canada or Germany or
England. Kind of interesting, isn't it?
They're most of them are from third
world countries. They're furthest away
from medical help and they live to be
old. So that we're beginning to collect
information here. The last one we want
to look at the National Geographic
Society, a very respected group of
people, scientists and and so forth and
support groups for science uh comes out
with a monthly magazine, the National
Geographic magazine of course and they
uh in January of 1973 came out with a
nifty special issue on longevity. They
they looked at cultures whose people
live be 120 and they documented the
oldest living human being that they
could find based on their criteria. This
fellow by the name of Sharali Mismaloff
from Azerbaijan, a little country just
south of Russian Georgia in western
Russia today. They documented him as
being 167 years old. Remember this is
the National Geographic Society, not the
National Enquirer. 167 years of age and
they had a half-page picture of him
actually harvesting tea leaves in a tea
plantation, still working 8 hours a day,
6 days a week when he's 167. 5 months
later, May of 1973, Shalley Mismolof
turns 168, goes out and hose the garden
for reporters to show how vigorous he
is. Now, for at least 50, maybe 70
years, medical doctors in America have
been poo pooing the idea that you could
live well beyond 100. You know, people
who lived 115, 120, they were one in six
billion. It wasn't something that
everybody could look forward to. And
anybody who tried to teach people how to
live to be 110, 120, 140 were considered
charlatans and quacks and taking
advantage of uh older people. I was glad
to see this come out. This was a news
article in the USA Today newspaper in
October of 2000. And it was based on a
article in the journal Science, very
respectable journal. And what they said
was, "Forget 100. Try living past 120.
Humans possess a maximum life expectancy
longer than 120 years, which has been
the long theorized medical limit. In
fact, lifespans appear to be increasing
over time with no end in sight. Now, the
key part of this is now that there's no
doubt about it, everybody agrees that
human beings, including Americans, have
the genetic capacity to live well beyond
120. Doctors want to take credit for it.
The things that have actually increased
our longevity from 45 average lifespan
in 1895 to 75.5 today which is an
increase of about 30 and a half years.
Our sewers and good clean
water public health things. We don't
have chalera and leptosperosis and
tuberculosis in our food supply and our
water supply anymore. We have meat
inspection. We have public water works
and things. We have sewers. These are
the things that have extended our
lifespan. Then there's this salt thing.
You know, whether you believe it or not,
this medical dogma has really caused a
lot of problems in America. How many of
you have ever heard that using a salt
shaker is bad? You're going to get
hypertension, right? You're going to get
heart disease and stroke. What's the
first thing that a good farmer puts out
for his livestock? A salt block or a
salt lick, isn't it? There's nobody out
in a pasture telling a cow she's limited
to one lick a
day. I refuse to believe that my human
patients are dumber than a cow. Say,
"Look, go ahead and pick up a salt
shaker. You're going to see that
lightning won't strike you. You can go
ahead and salt your food. ation salt
your body nothing bad's going to happen
and 98% of my patients love it they
bring me hundreds of new patients every
month who want to use salt and not feel
guilty about it and 2% the bean counters
they say now while we love you and
respect you we have this highriced
cardiologist that says you're flying in
the face of all the weight of medical
evidence you can't tell people that um
they can use a salt shaker because
you're going to kill them with high
blood pressure and heart disease and
stroke and I've been vindicated in this
belief this was actually a study that
was published in the New York Times s
May 22nd 1996 and this study was
abstracted from JAMAMA the Journal of
the American Medical Association the
most prestigious medical journal in the
world according to
themselves now in this particular
journal a Dr. Alexander Gordon Logan
who's an epidemiologist and cardiologist
on the teaching staff of the medical
school at the University of Toronto up
in Canada and he took 56 existing
studies on hypertension or high blood
pressure and restriction of salt
combined the data from these 56 studies
which included 350 people. He threw away
all the conclusions and re-evaluated the
larger group and what he found out was
this. If you have normal blood pressure
and you restrict salt, it will not
prevent you from getting heart disease
or high blood pressure. If you have
hypertension or high blood pressure and
you restrict salt, 97% of those with
high blood pressure or hypertension who
restrict salt will not get any
measurable benefit. 97% will not get any
measurable benefit. Zero. 2 to 5% get
measurable benefit, but it's not
significant. They're only able to reduce
their blood pressure by 3.7 millimeters
of mercury. So, here's what Dr.
Alexander Gordon Logan said in JAMAMA
May 22nd, 1996. He said, "You might as
well go ahead and salt your food to
taste. It's a meaningless exercise. is
don't get paranoid about salt. It has
nothing to do with blood pressure
problems. There has never been one
single iota of proof that restricting
salt has any benefit. It's just one of
those medical myths, he called it, but
I'm going to call it a medical cocka.
Now, if it's not salt, what causes high
blood pressure? Well, it's not salt,
first of all, because salt is an
essential nutrient is a combination of
sodium and chloride, both of which you
need. And according to the American
Heart Association, the minimum daily
requirement for 150 lb person for salt
each day is a heaping teaspoon, 6 to9
gram of salt a day. Now, the Japanese
who live longer than we do, the Japanese
who live 4.1 years longer than we do and
have half the cancer rate, they eat 12
grams of salt a day. They eat three
times the salt we do and they live four
years longer, have half the
cardiovascular disease
rate and half the cancer rate we do. And
yet they eat three times as much salt as
we do. So you're beginning to put the
puzzle together that doctors really
don't know what they're talking about.
That's why dead doctors don't lie. Well,
if it's not the salt and if it's not
genetic, what is it? Well, it's actually
just a simple mineral deficiency. Raise
your hand. You ever heard that
cholesterol is bad and you got to get it
low in your blood. You got to have low
cholesterol diet, otherwise you're going
to get heart disease, right? Doctors
would like to blame all cardiovascular
disease on cholesterol. We've known for
75 years in the animal industry that
cholesterol is not a boogeyman. There's
not a single disease that's caused by
elevated blood cholesterol or
triglycerides. If you can find me one,
I'll give you a million dollars in small
bills in any offshore account you want.
There's not a single disease that's
caused by elevated blood cholesterol or
triglycerides. Elevated blood
cholesterol and triglycerides are really
just a warning signal, much like a
fever. Fevers don't cause infections.
But when you have an infection with a
bacteria, a virus, a fungus, maybe a
parasite, you can get a fever. You can
have a broken leg and get a fever. You
can have cancer and get a fever. You can
have liver disease and get a fever.
Babies get a fever when they tee. And so
you have to kind of sort it out. When
somebody comes into a doctor's office
with a fever, you have to say, "Well,
okay, here's my whole list called a
differential diagnosis. All the things
that cause fever. If they're 80 years
old, you can quickly rule out teething,
right?" But the rest of them you may
have to do some lab tests for. Any rate,
the same thing is true for elevated
blood cholesterol and triglycerides.
When you have elevated blood cholesterol
and triglycerides, it might mean that
you have hypothyroidism or low
functioning thyroid gland. You could
have diabetes. You could have
deficiencies of nascin, chromium,
venadium, the essential fatty acids. You
could have liver disease. All kinds of
reasons why you might have elevated
blood cholesterol and triglycerides, but
they themselves don't cause any
problems. Now, the Eskimos above the
Arctic Circle have a traditional diet.
There's 98% red meat and blubber. Uh
they eat whale meat, whale blubber,
walrus meat, walrus blubber, seal meat,
seal blubber, bear meat, bear fat.
There's not a single Eskimo above the
Arctic Circle that has a Mr. Their juice
man juicer eats our gangly grown
broccoli. Their average cholesterol
ranges from 250 to 350. And yet they're
legendary for not getting cardiovascular
disease until they come down to the
lower 48 and eat like us. Then when they
get the cardiovascular disease, they go
back home to die up above the Arctic
Circle. They start eating whale blubber
again. It goes away. Well, learning all
that, I felt very confident in telling
my patients, look, we're going to do
something different. My goal as a
physician is to have my patients die at
an average age of 100. I don't want my
patients down at 75.5. I want to give
them another 25 years. I want the
average lifespan for my patients to be a
hundred. And we're going to do something
different. If you want to do everything
that all the other doctors and patients
are doing, I want you to go to them
because I don't want you to lower my
average, right? We're going to do
something different. It's just real
simple. My favorite disease is
arthritis. I love arthritis. The reason
why I love arthritis is it's easy to
fix. And when you can fix something as
horrible and as debilitating, as painful
and as expensive and as miserable as
arthritis, you get kind of excited about
this concept of preventing and curing
diseases with nutrition. And so I tell
people about this arthritis thing all
the time. So let's have a quick look at
arthritis. Uh number one, 75 to 80% of
all Americans over the age of 50 get
arthritis to one degree or one type or
another. And according to the CDC, the
Center for Disease Control, 35 to 50
million baby boomers are going to get
arthritis in the next 7 to 10 years. And
there's not a single medical treatment
designed to prevent or fix it. Aspirin
certainly doesn't fix arthritis. Cause
gastric bleeding and death. Tylenol
doesn't fix arthritis. Causes 50,000
cases of kidney failure each year. 5,000
of which are so severe you need a kidney
transplant. Then there's ibuprofen,
Advil, and Alie. These things don't fix
arthritis and they cause liver disease
in two to 5% of the users including
liver cerosis even if you don't drink.
And then there's methtoresate and gold
shots. These things don't fix arthritis.
They subdue your bone marrow so you
can't make normal platelets and white
blood cells. And then you have the
granddaddies of all the medical
treatments for arthritis. Prennazone and
cortisone. They don't fix arthritis.
They subdue your immune system which
leaves you open to diseases far far more
horrible than arthritis. And prennazone
and cortisone accelerate the loss of
minerals from your bones. Something you
don't want when you have osteoporosis
and arthritis. Now, when these
prescription medications and
over-the-counter medications don't work
anymore to relieve pain and
inflammation, the only thing left for
you medically is joint replacement
surgery. And uh I I never like to send
my patients in for joint replacement
surgery because they never work out
well. In fact, many times you're worse
off after the surgery than you were
before the surgery. The advantage my
patients have always had is that I'm a
veterinarian as well as a physician. And
so, I always used to tell my patients,
look, we have all these nutritional
formulas designed to prevent and cure
diseases in animals, including
arthritis. And so I tried adapting
nutritional arthritis formulas designed
to prevent and cure arthritis in pigeons
and turkeys, dogs, cats, sheeps, pigs,
horses, cows, lions, tigers, and bears
to human use. It was no surprise to me.
It works just as well in humans as it
does in animals because it was designed
to prevent and cure arthritis in pigs.
And I've literally seen tens of
thousands of people who've had a
regrowth of cartilage, ligaments,
tendons, connective tissue, bone
foundation, bone matrix. Doesn't matter
if they're 20, 30, 40, 50, 60, 70, 80,
90. I've seen people 97 years old regrow
cartilage and bone. Even if they had
bone to bone arthritis, if there's blood
supply to that joint and that bone, they
will regrow uh bone and cartilage. Well,
of course, Harvard Medical School goes
berserk when you say stuff like that.
Well, like you can't say those things.
The only thing left for people when they
get bone to bone arthritis is joint
replacement surgery. And I I'd agree
with them. If the only raw materials
you're using is Tylenol and aspirin and
penazone and cortisone, we've learned
over 50 years that you can't regrow
cartilage and bone using those things.
One of the basic things of course the
Harvard Medical School jumped on to and
they said this is so ridiculous that
this couldn't work. And so they took 29
patients arthritis patients who had
failed to respond in any way to heroic
medical treatment for arthritis over 15
to 20 years. They took them off all
their medication. Wasn't working for
them anyway. Lined them up for joint
replacement surgery. They said, "Look,
for 90 days before we do the surgery,
they gave them a heaping tablespoon full
of groundup chicken cartilage in their
orange juice every morning for 90 days."
They were sort of chuckling in their
beer saying, "Nothing's going to
happen." Well, here's what happened. In
10 days, these people, these 29 people
had complete relief of pain,
inflammation, something they hadn't had
in 15 to 20 years. In 30 days, they
could now open up a new pickle jar that
never been opened without pain to the
fingers, wrist, elbows, and shoulders.
In 90 days, 28 of the 29 were clinically
cured. Now, this is from Harvard Medical
School in the Boston VA. That meant that
they had complete return to the range of
motion. All the pain, inflammation was
gone in their fingers and toes and hips
and knees and their neck. And certainly
many of them still had knots on their
fingers because it was only 90 days. And
you'd think they'd call me up, these
professors, you know, of medicine from
Harvard Medical School and from the
Boston VA, and say, "Look, Wallock, we
have to apologize to you. We've been
badmouthing you for 20 years, and why
don't you come up to Boston? Let's talk
about the whole thing." Here's what they
said. Quote, "After 3 months, it was
clear that the drug was beneficial."
Unquote, chicken cartilage had become a
drug in 90
days. Now, why would that happen? Well,
because you can't patent chicken carage.
And they convinced at the US patent
office that they were using a drug to do
this study. And they actually got a use
patent on chicken cartilage. And you
too, for 3,500 bucks a month can get
Harvard Medical School's chicken cartage
in a capsule for arthritis. Of course,
cartilage has condroin sulfate in it,
glucosamine sulfate, collagen. These are
all the basic raw materials to rebuild
cartilage and bone. Raise your hand if
you know what the red warning lies for
on the dashboard of a car truck. Back
before we had dials showing temperatures
and things, they used to use a red
warning light, right? It was called the
idiot light. And when that red warning
light came on, it meant that your engine
was heating up. You didn't have enough
coolant or oil or maybe you broke a fan
belt or split a radiator hose. And a
reasonable person would would pull the
vehicle, car, or truck over the side of
the road and deal with the problem. So,
you didn't burn the engine up. Even even
a Mercedes would burn up if you didn't
have enough coolant and oil and a fan
belt and a radiator hose. Then, of
course, the village idiot, that's why
they called the village idiot light or
the idiot light. They'd be driving
along. They see that red warning light
come on. They say, "I don't have time to
deal with this." So, they whip out their
pliers, they cut the wire, the red
warning light, they keep on driving.
Even a Mercedes will burn up if it
doesn't have oil, cooling, a fan belt,
and a radiator hose, right? And so, you
really have to be the village idiot to
do that. Nobody in their right mind
would do that to their vehicle. How many
of you know what pain is for? Raise your
hand if you know what pain is for.
That's pretty good. Most of you know
that pain is the red warning light for
your body. When you get pain in your
foot, your ankle, your leg, your knee,
your hip, your back, your shoulders,
elbows, wrist, and fingers, your body is
saying, "Don't use those joints. Don't
use those bones. Don't use those muscles
until you fix them." It's absolutely
criminal. Absolutely criminal for a
doctor to write you a prescription for a
pain reliever, an anti-inflammatory or
muscle relaxer, or any of those
combinations without rebuilding the
bones and the joints and the cartilage
at the same time. If they just give you
a pain reliever, just give you an
anti-inflammatory andor a muscle
relaxing without rebuilding the joints
and the bones at the same time, all
they're doing is cutting the wire of the
red warning light, you're going to wear
those bones and joints and cartilage out
faster and faster and faster. It's
actually a negative to be taking
painkillers and anti-inflammatories
without rebuilding the joints and the
bones at the same time. The reason why I
say no carbonated drinks and have been
doing that since 1964 is because
carbonated drinks actually will
neutralize your stomach acid and you
cannot efficiently absorb minerals,
digest protein, or absorb vitamin B12
without stomach acid. You have to have
stomach acid like battery acid. Doctors
have the criminal belief that you don't
need stomach acid. They give you all
these drugs to get rid of your stomach
acid, antacids, and they give you drugs
that stop producing stomach acid, right?
They don't want you to have stomach
acid. Absolutely criminal. You can't
digest food and absorb food without
stomach acid. I know most of you knew
that carbonated drinks neutralize
stomach acid. If you remember back 25,
50, 75 years ago when somebody would ask
their doctor say, "Look, I just ate a I
overeat. I over ate a Thanksgiving
dinner and I have heartburn and
indigestion. What do I do?" That was
before they had Zantac. They say, "Well,
take some Seven Up. Drink some ginger
ale. Drink some club soda. take take
some uh sparkling water because a
carbonation will neutralize your stomach
acid and give you some relief and it
would. Now, if you do that three times a
year, drink a carbonated drink three
times a year for Thanksgiving and
Christmas and Easter because you overeat
during those holidays, that's okay.
You're going to survive. But when you're
drinking two, three, four, five, six,
eight, 10 carbonated drinks a day,
you're not going to survive because over
the long haul, you will not be able to
absorb the nutrients. You're going to
get some horrible combination of
terrible diseases. This came out June of
2000 and this is a Harvard study on 460
junior high school girls in nth and tth
grade. And what they found out was that
those junior high school girls who drank
one non-colacarbonated drink every day,
they increase their risk of fractures
and osteoporosis as a teenager by 300%.
They found out that if they drank one
carbonated cola drink, a cola carbonated
drink every day, they increase the risk
of fractures and osteoporosis as a
teenager by 500%.
Now, do you think that this is more
dangerous for teenagers or adults? It's
much more dangerous for adults because
you only have 25% bone matrix and you're
very, very slow to recover where
teenagers have 40% bone matrix and they
can recover in a week's time. We learned
in 1957 from a turkey study uh where
they took 250,000 turkeys and they put
them on a complete turkey pellet trying
to get them to finish for market within
a few days or a week or so of each
other. And in the first 13 weeks, fully
half of them, 125,000 of them died.
Farmers were out there every morning.
They picked them up every morning by the
bushel basket full, took them to the
state diagnostic lab to see what they
died from. When they opened them up,
every one of them had died of a ruptured
aortic aneurysm. And one of the clever
pathologists says, "That's got to be due
to a copper deficiency because copper is
required to manufacture the elastic
fibers of arteries and skin and other
tissues. And the mechanism of an
aneurysm is identical to the mechanism
of a balloon on a weakened wall of a
tire. You know, when you hit a chuck
hole with your tire and you break the
cords, the internal pressure blows a
balloon. you overload that tire with
weight or heat it up on a highway, it
blows out. Same way with an aneurysm.
When you have a copper deficiency, you
get a breakdown of the elastic fibers uh
in that artery, the internal pressure,
even normal blood pressure will blow a
balloon in that artery. And a balloon in
an artery is called an aneurysm. And of
course, if it's in a strategic place
like the brain, crowded artery, the
coronary arteries, the large arteries,
the aorta to pulmonary artery, renal
arteries, they blow out, you die
suddenly, uh just like you've been shot.
Well, they got excited about this. they
doubled the amount of copper in these um
pellets. The next year they tried to
raise 500,000 turkeys and they did not
lose a single one from a ruptured
aneurysm. They went from a 50% loss to a
0% loss just by adding a little bit of
copper to those pellets. So they said,
"Well, maybe the same thing is true for
humans." And in 19 uh 58 they started
looking at copper deficiency in various
species of animals and humans. And
here's what they found out. The very
first symptom of copper deficiency is
white, gray, and silver hair. Copper is
required as a co-actor to manufacture
hair pigment. Doesn't matter if it's
blonde, red, brown, or black hair. And I
see a lot of copper deficiency in this
room. I can almost tell you which
people, men and women, who have colored
their hair, get pretty good at that
being a physician. And you don't want to
be like a medical doctor and just treat
the symptoms. If you're just coloring
your hair, you're treating the symptoms.
You need to do the basic thing of take
some colloidal copper. And if you don't,
uh, what's going to happen is, uh, you
get a breakdown of the elastic fibers in
your skin and you start getting crows
feet around the corners of your eyes and
your mouth. Parts of your anatomy begin
to sag. And you know you're in trouble
when your doctor tells you, "Look, I've
got a golf buddy down the hall who's a
plastic surgeon for $10,000. It'll make
you look 20 years younger. But you don't
need a facelift, a booby lift, a tummy
tucker, a derriè lift. All you need is
some copper and everything will come
back up just like you have a hydraulic
jack under it. It'll just come right
back up. Those elastic fibers tighten
right up. People say, "Francine, did you
get a facelift? You look great. You look
like you're 20 years younger." Now, if
you don't take some action at that
point, the next thing that happens is
you get a breakdown of the elastic
fibers and the large veins of your legs
and you get varicose veins. you don't
take action at that point, you get a
breakdown of the elastic fibers and
large veins of your exhaust pipe and you
get hemorrhoids. So, if you have
hemorrhoids, varicose veins, things that
sag, wrinkles, white, gray, or silver
hair, the odds are you have aneurysms
developing in you somewhere and you
don't want to, of course, die suddenly
of a ruptured aneurysm when your body's
been warning you for 10, 20, 30 years.
Just remember, people don't die suddenly
of an aneurysm. It may be you drop and
die. Think about old Albert Einstein. He
died of a ruptured aortic aneurysm at 68
years of age. What color was his hair?
He was famous for wild white hair,
wasn't he? Now, you'd like to think that
people who win the Nobel Prize in
medicine would at least live to be 75.5.
But they live to be 58 just like other
doctors. And of course, that's because
they are trained and they believe and
they practice. You can get everything
you need from your four food groups.
Doesn't matter if they win the Nobel
Prize or not. This guy here, Dr. George
Kohler, was the youngest person ever to
win the Nobel Prize in medicine in
history. 37 years old, wins the Nobel
Prize in medicine. and he won the Nobel
Prize in medicine for studying monoconal
antibodies which are antibodies trained
to attack cancer cells and if they ever
get this really working it'll be great
because they won't have to use
chemotherapy anymore which kills more
people than it saves 11 years after
winning the Nobel Prize in medicine Dr.
George Kohler now 48 drops dead of a
cardiopathy heart attack because he
believed you can get everything you need
from your four food roots didn't take
any selenium died of a cardiopathy heart
attack now I have to tell you why
athletes are early warning system couch
potatoes by definition are people who go
to extraordinary efforts not to sweat
right they make every human effort not
to sweat they're changing the TV
channels honey bring in the popcorn I'm
changing the channels son bring me the
TV guide I'm changing the channels by
contrast athletes have the attitude ude
no pain, no gain. And they're out there
sweating and working away, power
training, strength training, running,
and they sweat. Athletes, no matter age,
they sweat more in five years than couch
potatoes do in 70 years. And when you
sweat, you don't just sweat out
potassium and Gatorade, you sweat out
all 60 essential minerals. If you sweat
out all of your selenium and don't
replace it by supplementation, you're at
higher risk of getting a cardiamopathy
heart attack. You sweat out all of your
copper and don't replace it by
supplementation, you're at high risk of
developing an aneurysm and dying
suddenly have a ruptured aneurysm. You
sweat out all of your chromium and
venadium and don't replace it by
supplementation, you're high risk of
getting diabetes. And if you sweat out
all of your calcium and magnesium and
boron and zinc and sulfur and other
minerals are required for cartilage,
ligaments, tendons, connective tissue,
bone, you're going to get a joint and
bone injury. What is the biggest single
cause of an athletes career being ended
early? Joint and bone problems, right?
And that's because they sweat out all
the basic minerals that they need to
maintain those parts of their body and
they don't supplement with them because
doctors tell them that they can get
everything they need by eating their
four food groups. Well, what are the
early warning systems for mineral
deficiencies? We already told you about
white, gray or silver hair for a copper
deficiency. Liver spots or age spots in
the back of your hand, side of your face
or neck. These things are caused by a
selenium deficiency. And you know again
about selenium deficiency. Then of
course you have toe cramps, leg cramps,
you can have hypertension. And these
things are all caused by a deficiency of
calcium. And if you're an athlete at age
25 or 15 and you get a leg cramp as a
calcium deficiency, your body's telling
you if you don't stop drinking those
Pepsis and start supplementing with some
calcium, by the time you're 40, 50, 60
years old, you're going to have
arthritis and osteoporosis. But most
people say, "Wow, I got to get this high
price trainer. I need somebody who can
give me massage therapy because I have a
cramp." And they don't go and take their
supplements. 85% of the total mineral in
your body is a calcium. There's 147
different diseases you can get from a
calcium deficiency. We're just going to
quickly go over the top 10 when it comes
to number of people affected and the
amount of money involved. Let's look at
osteoporosis. The number 10 killer of
adults in the United States. Remember,
75% of the those over age 65 who
fracture a hip or major leg bone don't
live 90 days. Also, it's the most
horrible disease when it comes to human
misery and dollars expended.
Osteoporosis. Think of the special vans
and the lift gates and the ramps and the
elevators. The special plumbing in homes
and and public buildings, special
parking places, wheelchairs and walkers
and canes. Think of the beds and the
chairs that are little electric motors
that lift you up when you can't stand up
by yourself. Physical therapists, joint
replacement surgeries, pharmaceuticals,
doctor's visits. We're talking billions
and billions of dollars for nothing more
than a calcium deficiency disease. Now,
as horrible as a disease as osteoporosis
is in human beings, we don't have
osteoporosis in animals because we don't
have Blue Cross Blue Shield, major
medical hospitalization, Medicare and
Medicaid to pay for nonsensical surgical
treatments for mineral deficiency. We've
learned that by putting animals who are
weaned off their mother's milk on
calcium as soon as they're weaned, they
won't get arthritis osteoporosis. It's
amazing how that works. Receding gums,
dentists and dental hygienists will tell
you to floss and brush after every meal.
If you believe that works, I have some
oceanfront property in Montana to sell
you. If you have receding gums,
perodontitis, gingivitis, pyrhea, loose
teeth, bridges, and plates, you actually
have osteoporosis of the facial bones
and the jawbones. We don't get receding
gums in animals, even though they don't
floss or brush. That's because we've
taken care of the osteoporosis problem
in animals. Arthritis, 85% of all
arthritis is called wear and tear
arthritis. Osteoarthritis, degenerative
arthritis, ankylosing spondylitis. These
things are nothing more than
osteoporosis of the joint ends of the
bones. Hypertension, high blood
pressure, as you've learned, has nothing
to do with salt or salt restriction. 85%
of hypertension not related to kidney
disease, which is most of them not
related to kidney disease, is in fact a
calcium deficiency. Insomnia is not a
deficiency of sleeping pills, calcion,
or barbituates. It's a deficiency of
calcium. kidney stones, bone spurs, heel
spurs, and calcium deposits. Again, the
medical profession has a malignant dumb
belief that these things are due to too
much calcium in your diet. Tell you to
give up calcium. When in fact, you only
get kidney stones, bone spurs, heel
spurs, and calcium deposits when you
have raging osteoporosis. You actually
need more calcium, more magnesium, not
less. Cramps and twitches. Raise your
hand. How many of you ever had a toe
cramp, foot cramp, leg cramp in your
life? Sure. That's the first symptom of
a calcium deficiency that most people
recognize. So if you've ever had that
sometime in your life, you've had a
calcium deficiency. Then you have PMS.
The University of California, San Diego
came out and said that 85% of the
emotional and physical stuff of PMS can
be relieved, eliminated, and cured. They
use the cure word by taking three times
the RDA of calcium. Low back pain has
nothing to do with disc problems. I know
you've heard of people, maybe even
yourself, have had a disc surgery for
back pain, and after the surgery, you
still had the pain, maybe even worse,
because back pain is not caused by disc
problems. If you have a disc problem,
you can have numbness and tingling,
maybe even paralysis if it's very
severe, but disc problems do not cause
pain. We learned in 1957 in animals that
we could prevent and cure adult onset
diabetes with two trace minerals,
chromium and venadium. In 1985, the
medical school at the University of
Vancouver, British Columbia up in Canada
came out and said the trace mineral
venadium alone could replace insulin and
adult onset diabetics. Science diet dog
food has 40 minerals in it. always has
chromium, venadium, lithium, and
selenium. Rolston laboratory rat pellets
has 28 minerals. Always contains
chromium, venadium, lithium, and
selenium. I'll give anybody in this room
a crisp new $100 bill. If you can find
me a human infant formula off the shelf
of a grocery store that has more than 12
minerals in it. None of them can contain
chromium, venadium, or lithium. Only one
pro soy, well, two actually, prozo and
infamill, I believe, has 12 because they
put in the um selenium. The rest of them
don't. They have 11, 10, nine or eight
minerals. Our dogs get 40 minerals. Our
rats get 28. And our kids get 12 or
less. You don't have to be a research
scientist to realize why our kids are
now getting all these horrible diseases
that used to occur in people in their
60s, 70s, and 80s. All these diseases
that that um doctors are wondering, how
is this genetic? These kids shouldn't
have this till they're 60. Well, that's
because they couldn't get it out of
their little can of stuff. If it's not
in the can, they don't get it. Again, we
need nutrients. 60 minerals, 16
vitamins, 12 essential amino acids,
three essential fatty acids. And
fortunately, over the thousands of years
that human beings have been around, we
haven't had to think much about this
because our food plants, our grains,
vegetables, fruits, and nuts, take
carbon dioxide out of the air and
manufacture long carbon chains, many of
which are vitamins, amino acids, and
fatty acids. And this is where this
medical kaka came from that you can get
everything you need from your four food
groups because they say, "Well, plants,
grains, fruits, vegetables, and nuts can
manufacture vitamins, amino acids, and
fatty acids." But we've tried this
experiment for 200 years. Americans have
eaten better than anybody else in the
world. We've had the best quality food
in the world over anybody else. And yet
we only live to be 75.5. We don't set
any health or longevity records. So if
you want to live to be over 100, can't
get it from eating your four food
groups. You can live to be 75.5. You may
live 10 years older, 10 years younger,
but on the average 75.5. So if you want
to live to be over 100, you do have to
supplement with vitamins, amino acids,
and fatty acids. There's uh three types
of minerals you have to concern yourself
with. First of all, there's metallic
minerals. These are things like oyster
shell, eggshell,
limestone, coral calcium, seabed
minerals, clays of various types. Tums
is a popular one with doctors. Lactates,
gluconates, citrates, oxides, sulfates,
carbonates. These are nothing but
groundup rocks. We're not designed to
eat ground up rocks. Nobody can show you
we're humans or animals are designed to
eat ground up rocks. We are designed to
get our minerals by eating plants,
grains, vegetables, fruits and nuts. And
as a result, plant- derived minerals are
absorbable, more absorbable than
chelated, more absorbable than the
elemental or metallic minerals. Plant
derived minerals are liquid. They're
very small particle size. They're 7,000
times smaller than a red blood cell.
This is the way they're stored in your
cells and are moved around in plant
vascular systems and human vascular
systems in the liquid plant derived
form. They're negatively charged. I
don't know all of the physics and the
chemistry is one of the basic features
of a colloidal mineral that's negatively
charged. These three factors together
give you absorbability. Now the way it's
supposed to be is our food plants are
grains, vegetables, fruits and nuts take
the elemental or metallic minerals out
of the soil, convert them to minerals
for their own use, for their own
metabolism and biochemistry and then
animals and people eat these plants that
are enriched with minerals. That's how
we're designed to get our minerals.
Unfortunately, we have several problems
here. For 100 years, we've used a simple
fertilizer known as NPK. We put in three
nutrients into the soil when we need 60
minerals. We put those three nutrients
in the soil for maximum yields per ton
and bushel per acre. Uh then of course
we have to understand that plants cannot
manufacture minerals. If they're not in
the soil, they're not in the plants.
Plants only have minerals in them if
they're in the soil. Plants cannot
manufacture minerals. Over 90 years at
least, we've been deficient in our soils
in America. And as a result, our food is
deficient. And as a result, the crops,
the grains, fruits, vegetables, and nuts
that are grown there are mineral
deficient. And as a result, the animals
and people who eat these mineral
deficient crops get mineral deficiency
diseases. And the only way to prevent
and cure them is with mineral
supplements.
[Applause]